changement de tripes élections
municipales dimanche dernier beaucoup
d'hommes politiques qui ont été prises
avec la justice
ou même qu'ils sont toujours en mis en
examen ont gagné ou ont perdu de
justesse c'est le cas de jean tiberi
dans le cinquième de mellick monsieur
mellick qui était en tête au premier
tour à béthune qui a pas été élu mais
deux d'une soixantaine de voix françois
bernardini à istres andré labarrère à
pau jean-jacques de peretti à sarlat
christian nucci du carf aux
développements à beaurepaire gilles
catoire à clichy alain juppé à bordeaux
dsk dominique strauss kahn à sarcelles
robert hue à montigny-lès-cormeilles ça
fait quand même beaucoup de gens et
certains ont rappelé à la prime à la
casse roll c'est à dire que finalement
le fait d'avoir des problèmes avec la
justice n'a pas empêché tous ces hommes
politiques d'être réélue dimanche et
pour en parler ce soir avec nous l'un
des plus contestées voici patrick
balkany maire
patrick balkany bonsoir alessandra
martinez
eric et ramzy michèle bernier vous
connaissez tous le monde dont vous avez
gagné les municipales à levallois avec 8
points de plus que votre adversaire
olivier de chazeaux malgré comme je le
disais donc une condamnation à 15 mois
de prison avec sursis et 2 ans
d'inégibilité pour avoir employé des
agents de la mairie chez vous à l'époque
vous étiez maire de levallois employez
des gens qui étaient des salariés de la
mairie dans votre dans votre appartement
et vous avez été reconnue comptable de
fait ce que dira que donc c'est votre
responsabilité est d'ailleurs vous devez
encore enfin vous dirai ce que vous en
pensez mais vous devez encore 3,4
millions de francs à la commune de
levallois voilà
en plus de ça j'ai toujours mis en
examen dans la sphère des hlm des
hauts-de-seine pour trafic d'influencé
voilà alors
répondez sur les deux faces les chefs
d'accusation a déjà un d'abord en ce qui
concerne le personnel c'était du
personnel que je prenais effectivement à
la mairie quand je recevais des
investisseurs des gens dont on avait
besoin levallois ce n'était pas pour mon
usage personnel
car ce que je préfère au monde s'émeut
mettre le samedi soir avec un plateau
devant la télé pour regarder tout le
monde en parle en tirer voilà alors mais
va lui ressemble et en plus c'est
bien je me mets en noir paris tu es et l
affaire du trafic d influence dans les
hlm non je vous ai c'est une très
vieille histoire les hlm dès qu'on
parlait d' hlm on mettait tout le monde
en examen alors quand j'étais président
d'un des plus gros office de france on a
mis en examen c'est vrai pour complicité
de trafic d'influencé je ne sais pas qui
a fait du trafic d'influencé je ne sais
pas de quoi je suis complice mais il ya
très longtemps et j'en ai plus jamais
entendu parler donc vous vous dites je
suis blanc comme neige quoi
j'ai fait une erreur avec le personnel
communal effectivement parce que j'ai
pas pris une délibération
josé conseil municipal vous avez dit
vous pouvez les prendre la voie ça voyez
pas été exactement je dois dire que ça
c'est ma faute je n'ai pas fait voter
une délibération au conseil
principal que tout le monde aurait volé
un bailleur cela on peut penser quoi est
ce qu'on appelle la prime à la casse
roll c'est à dire le fait que tous les
gens que j'ai cités là en commençant que
je sus des problèmes avec la justice et
est réélu ou battu de justesse quoi je
crois que ça n'a rien à voir j'avais des
gens qui sont proches de leurs
populations qui sont aimés par la
population qui sont bon maire et vous en
avez qui sont mauvais mère j'ai été
pendant douze ans maire de levallois de
83,95 exactement ensuite
j'ai eu six ans de vacance est à peu
près et mon successeur eh bien il n'a
pas accroché avec la population il a il
n'a pas eu d'histoire bon il m'a attaqué
mon adresse à apa plus sympa du tout plu
aux gens et les levalloisiens aurait
préféré qu'ils s'occupent d'eux plutôt
que de s'occuper de moi
moi je me suis toujours occupé d'eux et
c'est ce qu'ils apprécient et maintenant
ils demandent mais que le maire revienne
série mentalist qui est simple escape à
un repli local des gens par rapport la
république des juges je crois qu'il faut
pas généraliser il faut pas généraliser
les maires
sont des gens en général qui sont très
proches de leur population c'est la
catégorie politique la plus aimée 1 en
france vous voyez dans tous les sondages
les gens aiment bien leur mère avec les
clowns si c'est vrai c'est les préférés
des enfants
oui oui mais finalement il ya plus de
mer que de clown
matri donc vous dites moi je suis
réhabiliter deux façons par le suffrage
universel et quand le jeu croire et ses
13 ans préfet des anciens démocratie
ouais quand le préfet des hauts-de-seine
conteste votre élection vous dites c'est
insultant pour suffrage universel
absolument quand même bon vous dites
c'est quand même bon se dire quelqu'un
qui a fauté par rapport la société s'il
est élu au suffrage universel ça ne
fasse sa faute alors quand vous avez
fauté c'est comme votre permis de
conduire quand on vous l'enlève pour un
mois on vous ne l'enlève pas pour toute
la vie oui moi j'ai eu deux ans
d'inéligibilité en 96 on est en 2001 et
aujourd'hui il ya quelques mois quand je
suis revenu le maire a dit ah ben je
vais appeler la cour des comptes dans le
fond il pourrait peut-être nous redonner
encore un peu d'argent et puis on va
leur condamné une deuxième fois en
france y'a pas de double peine 1 en
europe non plus quand vous avez été
condamné pour un fait d'accord vous ne
pouvez pas de congés payés géant voix
voilà non seulement j'ai périgée telus
bon voilà bon et j'ai payer des dommages
et intérêts à la ville et j'ai été
lourdement imposé car en plus on m'a
pris ça en avantages en nature vous êtes
obligés en appartement oui on va en
parler alors vous avez été élu sans
étiquette un dvd ce qui éteint hier à
droite ya celle de la vierge
un divers droite dans les nouveautés
évidemment ça c'est moderne comme truc
alors que chazot votre votre concurrent
du rpr lui les repères officielle et
puis en plus c'est l'ami de mam de
michèle alliot-marie penser que cela des
services à je ne sais pas c'est une
femme charmante obama en mai il avait
effectivement toutes les avec cette
interview mensonge
ils avaient toutes les investitures tour
f ça lui a pas servi à grand chose c'est
moi qu'on puisse dire il y en a d'autres
qui vous accusent de clientélisme et de
populisme c'est vrai que tous ces maires
qui sont très aimée c'est souvent parce
qu'ils font du clientélisme d'un squale
clientélisme si c'est s'occuper des gens
quand ils ont un problème quand ils ont
un problème d'appartements quand ils ont
un problème d'emploi mais oui alors ça
je suis pour
alain barrière 1 maria bravo je suis pas
le meilleur service mais déjà vous
commencez toujours pas sur le public
patrick balkany vous êtes dans 48 à
neuilly sur seine votre père s'appelait
giulia c'est ça joue la wii immigrés
juifs hongrois résistants développe t il
a fait fortune dans le prêt-à-porter de
luxe les annales les magasins réty et je
me souvienne ça il veut dire nature
publicitaire et ils n'ont absolument
très marqué mon enfance à l'oreille du
magasin de champs elysées faubourg
saint-honoré et vous est ce qu'on peut
dire c'est un petit peu un fils à papa
non oui sauf que j'ai commencé par
travailler dans le prêt-à-porter alors
j'ai commencé à écouter oui absolument
pour trouver un boulot très tendance
j'ai pas j'ai pas galérer vraiment
lancer dans des pensions plutôt sélect
collège du monde celle jouy en josas
solu vous partager une chambre et michel
sardou henri iv en même comment c'était
alors que l'ue vient la semaine dernière
qui me souvenais par les allées après et
après on était avec fugain au cours de
comédie
c'est une bande de potes oui absolument
après six années dans un lycée privé en
suisse
effectivement vous avez fait un cours
d'art dramatique
vous êtes débrouiller pour faire du
cinéma exact il faisait jouer dans j'ai
tué raspoutine
on séchait qu il faisait le grand duc
dimitri voila voila c'est un film de
robert hossein en fait vous lier deux
comédiens on n'est pas oui mais il est
resté
en quelque sorte sauf que je joue mon
propre texte un coin voilà et puis alors
après on fait le service militaire hélas
il était un petit peu pistonné pour
rentrer j'ai eu un gros coup de poing je
suis arrivée à l'elysée un peu par
hasard ouais voilà je suis passé du
bourget à l'elysée mais classement
version réalisée on parce que mon père
avait des copains navires etc bon et
puis c'est vrai que retis était en face
de l'elysée fait désirer
voilà alors vous êtes donc au service de
presse de la présidence pendant la
présidence de georges pompidou met
absolument que je serai ici genre si tu
nous regardes et donc vous portez vous
portez les dépêches mais maintenant dans
votre curriculum vitae vous dit vous
êtes passés au cabinet de georges
pompidou quand même franchi en j'ai
toujours faire j'ai toujours dit que
j'avais fait mon service militaire à
l'elysée gt gt très heureux parce qu'à
22 ans est vrai que je faisais la revue
de presse un président de la république
et que toutes les heures j'amenais les
dépêches de toutes les agences de presse
c'était juste un service somme toute
très sympathique et qui vous ouvre des
perspectives c'est vrai donc jusque là
pas trop de problèmes voilà une vie
plutôt sympa et alors après le service
de rencontrer celle qui est devenue
votre femme isabelle smadja donc est une
fille d'une famille assez fortunée aussi
oui on peut le dire
familier à soustelle lazareff sont donc
j'étais le patron de combat voilà déjà
et donc ça vous permet quand même
d'accéder assez vite au comité central
du rpr au moment de la création 76 77 gt
gt dans les 100 premiers membres du
central oui alors donc pasqua vous vous
remarque à cette époque et vous devenez
ce qu'on appelle un pasqua boys
ça fait envie c'est à dire que charles
pasqua a donné leur chance à beaucoup de
jeunes d'entre eux 23 qui ont été élus
dans un certain nombre de 180 phrase est
élu donc à levallois au municipal maire
de levallois abcès réélu en 89 vous êtes
député en 88 et vous resterai maire de
levallois jusqu'en 95 des députés
jusqu'à 90 elle voilà exactement
alors quand vous êtes maire de levallois
vous vous transformez que cette banlieue
populaire en une espèce de nuit c'est
pas une espèce de neuilly c'est une
ville où il ya cinquante cinq mille
habitants et 50000 emplois parce que
quand je suis arrivé dans la ville il y
avait que des usines qui était en train
de péricliter il y avait les usines de
deux chevaux citroën qui était en train
de fermer et pour l'économie de la ville
il a fallu faire venir des entreprises
se battre avec les pouvoirs publics pour
construire des des bureaux des logements
des équipements tout genre et je les
fais pendant 12 ans et je crois que les
levalloisiens on était très heureux de
toute cette transformation à preuve
c'est qu'ils viennent de vous relire
donc voilà bon hein vous créer une
police municipale oui alors il avait on
les appelait les cowboys c'est vrai oui
non c'était la première police
municipale qui a été créée en ile de
france voilà les mères isolées dans 457
magnum cher mais
c'est normal mais sont tous armés c'est
pour la sécurité et on a créé aussi la
vidéosurveillance oui on a été aussi les
premiers et maintenant tout le monde
réclame et des polices municipales c'est
la vidéosurveillance et on est nombreux
à ces horribles
je sais que c'est horrible
des caméras partout il y en a partout et
richissime regardez vous avez
choisi une balade à levallois au petit
fils mais au moins on n'est pas agressé
comme ça oh je suis pas sûr que ce soit
vraiment le remède un progrès c'est vous
avez j'habite à gennevilliers à chaque
fois je traversais levallois j'avais
peur de me faire agresser par votre
police municipale
ait jamais rien fait moi on sait jamais
là bas en tout cas vous avez été
condamné en attendant donc nous pour
l'instant ça va quoi la 5000 cours
privés
[Musique]
valence bien non ce qu'on peut dire
quand même si vous êtes transformé un
peu le valoir une sorte de monaco n'ont
qu'à une espèce de petit endroit comme
ça sur protéger non mais c'est vrai
c'est un c'est une ville où il fait bon
vivre ouais trois paires sécurité matin
j'ai dû prendre que ça fait deux ans
qu'elle utilise la marche bien alors
vous achetez donc un appartement fin 500
m² en face de la mairie construite alors
j'ai quitté neuilly pour partir à
levallois mais quand ils ont construit
l'immeuble s'est réservée un duplex de
500 m² dont on avait un appartement à
neuilly en est vendu en a racheté à
levallois comme tout le monde c'est là
où travailler donc les fameuses employés
municipaux qui vous ont été tellement
ils sont choyés municipaux venait
m'aider lorsque j'avais besoin d'eux
voilà là il ya un problème c'est que le
juge halphen fameux juge halphen
s'intéresse aux hlm des hauts-de-seine
et surtout au directeur de l'office des
hlm des hauts-de-seine didier schuller
il a une sombre histoire
où le beau père du juge halphen monsieur
maréchal est mêlé à une tentative de
chantage sur schuller enfin c'est ce que
vous en tous les cas vous accréditer
comme thèse vous dites je ne sais pas
lequel des deux donc entre schuller et
halphen risque le plus la prison écoutez
c'est de la très vieille histoire et
histoires faire c'est une preuve
qu'elles sont pas réglés des histoires
regarde et raconte l'histoire sixtine
très vieille histoire est tombé c'est
visiblement une histoire de famille
entre maréchal et halphen beau père elle
juge moi je suis jamais rentrer là
dedans ouais dans tous les cas le juge a
été dans un premier temps dessaisi du
dossier de la scène à cause de cette
affaire maréchal et puis plus tard il a
quand même été lavé de tout soupçon
c'est à dire qu'il ya eu une annulation
de la procédure voilà tout simplement
vous pensez qu'il y avait vraiment un
vrai problème pensez pas que c'est un
montage total ah non absolument pas mais
bon faut seulement pas parce que votre
ami schuller lui par auberge à ce nom je
crois qu'il a eu très peur et la peur
obama bah oui tu veux je sais pas où il
est parti c'était si vous savez bien
c'était le directeur de l'office de hlm
donc des hauts-de-seine et lui il est
parti aux bahamas quand il a vu arriver
tout ça et ensuite
quand vous perdez la mairie en 95 et
vous êtes condamné
lui vous vous balance quand même sous
leur nom je ne sais pas j'ai jamais une
nouvelle vous savez
malheureusement il est parvenu ou
malheureusement il est parti il aurait
jamais dû partir mais non qui dit
malheureusement sérieusement non
sérieusement parce que je crois que y'a
vraiment pas grand chose dans l'est dans
les dossiers
c'est c'est pas l'affairé elf après vous
allez prenez avec votre femme donc ça
s'arrange pas vous séparer pendant un an
oui mais vous savez dans un couple ça
fait 25 ans qu'on est marié temps en
temps j'ai pris la petite clé
et vous ne mangeons pas tout ainsi il
était en prison c'est quasiment
celui là changer de femme sait pas
combien de toi moi j'ai toujours la même
avez vous ai repris la même après au
bout des marchés s'est
si bien dit en 97 et exclue du groupe
rpr donc à l'assemblée nationale en 97
on est dissous ouais vous savez oui on
va aller jusqu'à 98 97 ans et demi en
vacances voila voila je me représente
pas ouais et je prends deux années
sabbatiques aux caraïbes
4 nages non juste un connard martin en
france à saint martin bien en france à
ma ville française vous savez qui dit
attendre deux heures et sympathique
autant les pandas saint-martin soient
ouvertes payer entre nous la nama la bad
ont retrouvé stéphane collaro carlos l'a
fait c'est le genre les gens qui
c'est les gens qui habitent là-bas la
pêche au gros
la classe johnny johnny il vient il a
lui aussi la prise six mois sabbatiques
1 à saint-martin et vous dirigez une
radio dans un endroit qui s'appelle
mariko soi même énorme c'est la capitale
de saint-martin vrai mais c'est fou non
vous avez vraiment l'esprit management
et votre femme fait de la décoration et
il y encore samassa voilà alors vous
revenez vous revenez aux besoins de
huy sabbatique vous revenez bah oui
parce que vous savez les îles les
cocotiers tout ça c'est très agréable
génial quand on y passe quinze jours
c'est très bien un mois c'est vrai qu'au
bout de deux ans vous faire servir un
bureau de vote
je suis content si bien dire
c'est que lorsque non ce que patrick
revient avec sa femme isabelle bel
appartement ayant été vendus ils sont
obligés d habiter chez leur fille oui
parce que ma fille habite à levallois
quand on est à levallois elle nous met
ses grands chez elle jean mais rassurez
vous elle est célibataire avant
n'accorde pas l'essai les célibataires
je vais même vous dire et elle vous
adore la bande quatre ans ah oui le mec
vos sacs
alors là si je sais pas
j'ai retrouvé à levallois il faut mettre
pierre hémon soit connu voilà bien à toi
les employés de mairie
jusqu'au cou pas augmenter d'ailleurs
les employés de mérite ce quand je suis
parti y en avait on se sent bien
figurez-vous quand je reviens il y en a
14 oui c'est quand même extraordinaire
et moi j'en utilise est que de temps en
temps alors vous voyez il y en a qui les
utilisent pas soit 300 bugs trouvés la
ville dans quel état est sérieux un peu
dégradée très honnêtement c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qui m'ont réélu c'est par
hasard touche pour mettre dans les mains
d'un homme non ils ont des villes d'oyse
ont des trottoirs sales ils ont une
alors déjà apparu sur
de faire bizarre
je vais vous dire ce de levallois oui à
l'aise il m'aime beaucoup c'est normal
oui il y en a même beaucoup qui ont voté
pour moi bien entendu monsieur moi alors
je suis bien d'accord avec vous mais
voilà moi je suis vite mais un petit peu
je n'ai jamais vu un monsieur quand je
passe j'ai peur de votre ville votre
police municipale est effrayante je vous
jure ça c'est pas vu ils ont des grandes
et des dents et una ça c'est plutôt que
non je vous jure sur votre peau lisse
avec les gens qui n'ont rien à se
reprocher n'ont jamais peur de la police
monsieur regardez vous pensez que c'est
un bandit et je ne serais pas là sinon
j'avais peur en passant de votre ville
qui est le bandit vous fait vous allez
faire rire là mais pas pour le
jure je vous plaint de ce que j'ai
vraiment foudre marc g ça m'a toujours
dégoûté ça de passer à levallois ça se
voit que j'ai pas la gueule de valable
de levallois et à la police municipale
qui direct aux toits veut voir papier
tout ça que tu fous là non je le jure
sur la tête de ma mère que c'est vrai la
police municipale n'arrête jamais
quelqu'un pour lui de bonne gestion
je vous ai je vous assure qu'elle n'a
pas le droit et si elle vous arrête pour
présenter ses papiers il faut appeler la
police nationale es le permets de vous
le demander quand même avec des armes à
la poche et des bombes lacrymo même sens
même son impressionnant ça doit être à
chicago ou alors vous avez vu ça dans
des films de série b road à vos caméras
de vidéosurveillance mais je vous jure
c'est vrai monsieur ginette et si vous
jure vous êtes en train de faire rire
tout levallois serge
sérieusement est-ce que vous pensez que
en étant parti dans les conditions qu'on
connaît en revenant en vous faisant
élire est-ce que vous pensez que vous
aidez la politique en agissant de la
sorte mais moi je je ne cherche pas à
aider la politique je cherche à aider la
ville dans laquelle je travaille depuis
tant d'années a progressé à aller de
l'avant j'essaye d'aider les
levalloisiens moi j'ai fais de la
politique pour aider les autres pour
servir uniquement comme vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure je n'avais pas besoin de
faire la politique je suis né dans une
famille où on avait tout ce qu'il
fallait il y avait une affaire il y
avait tout ce qu'il fallait je n'avais
vraiment pas besoin de politiques pour
gagner de l'argent comme certains
voudraient le laisser dire blessés
entendre moi j'ai fait de la politique
vraiment par conviction et je continue à
faire de la politique aujourd'hui si je
vous dévouez finalement pour levallois
s'est pas votre intérêt personnel c'est
pour la ville assad et ça l'a toujours
été et ça continuera à l'être et mon
épouse aussi et votre action votre tour
votre élection pour l'image de la
politique des hommes politiques pensez
que c'est bénéfique vous savez je sais
pas si l'image des hommes politiques est
aussi bénéfique pour moi en tout cas je
marche je me rends compte d'une chose
c'est que sans investiture je suis élu
d'autres avec les investitures de tous
les partis ne sont pas élus très bien on
rallume
[Applaudissements]
bien
en place et maintenant un petit
interview spéciale si vous le voulez
bien on a bouge pas pendant le guignol
[Musique]
bien interdits moralité est ce que vous
avez déjà appliquée dans le
porte-monnaie de votre maman quand vous
étiez petit dans le porte-monnaie de ma
maman orange est sûrement dû prendre de
quoi aller acheter à carambar ou et
l'accord de l'huile bâle iii
est ce que vous êtes déjà sortis et que
la copine d'un copain
j'ai beaucoup de copains ouais
un commerçant se trompe à votre avantage
en vous rendant l'âme n'ai voulu fait
remarquer oui tout de suite ça
m'arrivait sam
sam arrive malheureusement souvent je
trouve que les gens comptent de plus en
plus mal si votre côté fils de
commerçants si vous pensez à vos parents
non c'est mon côté n'être j'aime pas
qu'on me rende l'argent tu ne
m'appartient pas c'est pas l'interview
mensonge en a assez non c'est la vérité
vous imaginez un jeu de l'esprit vous
avez un appartement vous possédez un
appartement votre locataire peut plus
payer le loyer c'est un type odieux mais
vraiment odieux il a deux enfants
insupportables vous les [ __ ] dehors
jamais non jeu d'abord je ne loue pas
d'appartement parce que je
voudrais surtout pas me retrouver dans
ce genre de situation j'aime pas ça et
quand j'étais président de l'office
départemental des hlm c'est à dire 30000
logements dans les hauts-de-seine croyez
moi avant d'expulser
quelqu'un il fallait vraiment qu'on
puisse pas arriver à d'autres solutions
j'ai toujours fait en sorte que les gens
soient relogés soit aidé mis des
enquêteurs me des assistantes sociales
qu'un des piats ou non ses moi je les
fais par conviction
rien d'autre je les fais je n'ai pas
appris et en vue de gérer de gauche si
vous continuez comme ça mais je suis pas
de droite à ceyras couple non non je
sais pas ce que c'est la gauche et la
droite j'étais gaulliste la gauche s'est
partagé quand j'ai beaucoup d'argent
c'est partagé que les autres c'est à
gueuler de payer trop d'impôts toute la
journée parce qu'on sait que certains
réseaux torrent vous savez aujourd'hui
je sais pas j'ai pas la presse alors ça
a dû changer ça a dû beaucoup changer la
gauche partagée comment vous avez dit
partager partager le pouvoir non en ce
moment en vous cite à l'ordre du mérite
pour un acte héroïque en fait vous
n'avez pas fait vous étiez là quand ça
s'est produit et vous c'est pas vous qui
avait sauvé le môme de se faire écraser
est ce que vous dit rien vous prenez la
médaille au contraire je la remets à
celui qui l'a fait voyager le crois moi
aussi les corrections de nourrir un t2
inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou